my way of expressing myself as always in
physical my mom told me but since I was
little it's like if I would be angry or
happy or whatever you would see it in my
body language for me having a new way of
challenging my body and new way of
pushing the limits of what my body can
do that was the thing that really got me
hooked in flying my name is Inga Vita
and I'm a dancer and a world champion
indoor skydiver
I said a dancing when I was three years
old and as long as I remember I've been
dancing when indoor skydiving came along
I found something for the first time
that I was more passionate about than I
ever was about dancing suddenly I
realized like I've just found a new way
of dancing it's just on a different kind
of dance or the discipline that I
compete in is called freestyle but when
I'm speaking about my flying overall I
prefer to use the term air dancing
because it's not just about competing
and that sector discipline it's about
creating something new and luring the
limits of what we can do in flying and I
would like to take flying from being a
sport towards being a form of performing
arts flying for sure is way harder than
it looks like the wind speeds can go up
to 180 miles an hour you have to be
strong you have to be flexible a lot of
the body positions look easy but they
actually require a lot to perform them
nicely so a split for example it might
look like I'm just resting in in that
flexible body position but I'm actually
all the time pushing against the airflow
you have control
I don't always like the use of the word
talented because it makes it sound like
only if you have that talent before you
even start flying you're going to get
good I've always been like a hard worker
myself so if I really want to get good
at something I'm going to do whatever it
takes
it just depends on how much you want
[Music]
you
[Music]